Заклики запровадити візовий режим з Росією
лунають в Україні не вперше.
Зазвичай це аргументують інтересами безпеки
та агресією північного сусіда на Сході та в Криму.
Мовляв, з візами українським правоохоронцям буде
набагато легше контролювати росіян,
які приїжджають в Україну,
але можуть становити загрозу її безпеці.
Схожої думки - і західні експерти.
З точки зору безпеки я можу зрозуміти, звідки
така зацікавленість ідеєю запровадження віз.
Адже прикордонники хочуть отримати більше
адміністративних повноважень та краще контролювати,
хто в’їжджає в Україну з боку Росії і хто туди виїжджає,
як довго вони залишаються в Україні.
Запровадження віз для громадян держави-агресора -
цілком логічний крок, погоджується брюссельський експерт Пітер Клеппе.
Однак до нього українська влада мала вдатися іще три роки тому.
Нині ж візи для росіян можуть дати додаткові козирі
російській пропаганді, адже такими діями
Київ фактично провокує Москву.
А сама ініціатива, на його думку,
радше схожа на спробу політичних сил повернути
собі втрачений рейтинг перед наступними виборами.
Усе це схоже на популізм.
Нескладно заявити, що ми маємо знати,
хто приїздить до нашої країни.
Ясна річ, це серйозний аргумент.
Але в мене питання - якщо це настільки важливо і терміново,
чому така ідея виникла лише через три роки
після початку конфлікту з Росією?
Тож заяви політиків, про те, що вони керуються
міркуваннями безпеки - доволі сумнівні.
Сумніваються у реалістичності цієї ініціативи
і самі її ініціатори.
Формально немає жодних перепон для того,
щоб повернутися до питання віз для росіян,
адже відповідна постанова вже пройшла затвердження у комітеті.
Але навіть якщо це питання і дІйде до сесійної зали,
перспектива зібрати необхідні голоси доволі примарна.
Адже дотепер консенсусу у Верховній Раді з цого питання не було.